dans la jeune vingtaine et déjà ils
pressaient le début de son parcours vers
la scène fédérale prête à lutter pour le
droit des autochtones et 1e prix pour
une trentaine d'années de militantisme
qui ont permis à lausanne thibauld de
briser le plafond de verre
la chef de l'ontario devient la première
femme à la tête de l'assemblée des
premières nations
une victoire pour toutes les femmes est
un symbole d'espoir pour celle au
grandes ambitions
j'ai été sollicité pour le national et
j'avais toujours cette crainte là on
n'est pas prêt on n'est pas prêt et
c'est sûr dans meilleur ce matin je me
dis je fière elle et le rosé rosen un
job incarne un désir de renouveau c'est
un trouble c'est vraiment un temps
difficiles alors là je pense que la
communauté le dit mais là on va
peut-être prendre une perspective
différente
on essaie avec une femme qui est très
fort au sommet de sa liste de priorités
la recherche des sites d'anciens
pensionnats pour autochtones du far west
au-delà des enjeux qui ont fait les
manchettes ces dernières semaines
d'autres problèmes perdurent dans les
communautés autochtones problèmes d'eau
potable racisme dans le système de santé
des défis liés aux changements
climatiques
la nouvelle chef s'est doté d'un plan de
100 jours pour y apporter des pistes de
solution c'est beaucoup de travail
la tête de mini-gouvernement sont les
attentes des communautés sont grandes à
peine il eut la nouvelle leader doit
déjà se défendre face aux critiques
l'assemblée des premières nations a
lancé une enquête à son sujet sur des
allégations d'intimidation et de
harcèlement ports internes obtenus par
ces piscines ne révèle aucun détail sur
la sphère d'un windows phone mais il n'y
a jamais eu de plainte officielle dit
elle
aucune rencontre pour discuter de ce
rapport maintenant il lui vaut entre
bolt doit rassembler les trop seulement
50% les chefs avaient voté pour et elle
même après le 5e tour de scrutin
marchi balle va parler à tout le monde
mais de dire de rassembler tout le monde
ça va être à nous aussi de marcher à
côté d'elle de la soutenir la nouvelle
chef assure que son expérience politique
lui permettra de rallier les membres une
image n'a semblé forte et unie qui sera
essentiel pour pousser le gouvernement à
respecter ses engagements envers les
premières nations
ici julian lapointe radio canada ottawa